they created
a ship of dreams it had to be the
ultimate
climax for their lives but for nine
shipbuilders aboard the titanic the
dream
became a nightmare and the nightmare
became a commodity
100 years later a global market for all
things titanic
leaves the ship itself exposed the
titanic
is really a deep-sea museum
with the doors wide open that's my
uncle's graveyard
and you don't desecrate a great national
geographic
explorer in residence robert ballard
discovered the ship
27 years ago now he fears the titanic
will be lost
again if the titanic is not protected
it'll get stripped until all the jewels
have been taken off the old lady's body
the titanic is a dark and silent grave
here every object tells a story
of triumph luxury
and loss
even the humblest artifacts fuel a
legend
that captivates millions
[Music]
the thought that within a few days she
just disappeared to the ocean
lost forever i'm an engineer betrayed so
i'm interested in the mechanical and how
the ship works
of the things i collect i think the
things that interest me pertain to
people
this is where collectors put a price tag
on the global fascination with the
titanic
twice a year titanic enthusiasts descend
on a small town in the english
countryside
to visit the auction house of henry
aldridge's son
we are the world's leaders in the sale
of titanic memorabilia
we have sold hundreds and hundreds of
items we hold every world record
relating to the sale of titanic
memorabilia
these tiles will cost three or four
hundred pounds
here is a remarkable item be worth
between two or three thousand pounds
something like this will be worth
between three and five thousand pounds
this card was posted from the titanic so
this card is worth several thousand
pounds one of the most anticipated items
in the auction
is a set of keys from a first-class
men's lavatory
and what's significant about these
they're from the titanic
so they're worth between 30 and 50 000
pounds
it all comes down to what collectors are
willing to bid to own a piece of
titanic's history
we have phone bids registered from
around the world we've got bills from
the u.s
bidders from china bidders from thailand
i particularly collect menus china is my
main interest
i have always collected to china save my
pennies and then spend them all and then
save my pennies and spend them all
they've got some fantastic stuff in the
auction one-off things which will
probably never appear again
and i suspect items like that will just
go through the roof
as a reputable auction house aldridge
and son
carefully researches the origins of
every artifact
and never deals in objects recovered
from the ocean floor
but in such a lucrative market serious
titanic collectors know
there's a dark side i think people have
always been interested in
the idea of going down and retrieving
objects from the debris field
and the threat is real someone said
something once about a rivet that
someone offered them for about 10
000 pounds from a wreck as long as
you've got proof that it's from the
titanic
you can name the price
a black market in titanic artifacts is a
nightmare scenario for dr
robert ballard the titanic is really
a deep sea museum
with the doors wide open there's no lock
on the door and there's no guard
ironically much of today's fascination
with the titanic
stems from balor's discovery of the
shipwreck in 1985
oh
the boiler for me was the signature
image
that told us we'd found the titanic
there were two people inside of me at
that moment the
professional who was elated and happy
and excited
then there was a human inside of me it
was exact opposite feeling
a sense of remorse a sense of
you know we shouldn't be celebrating
anything
we're at the spot where this amazing
tragedy this amazing drama had unfolded
dr ballard's discovery unleashed an
explosion of interest in the titanic
attracting tourists and treasure hunters
to the site
according to the law of the sea ballard
and his team
could have claimed the titanic as their
own property by removing a single
artifact
when we found the titanic it wouldn't
have been that difficult to go back
and pick up something but after a lot of
thought we decided not to disturb the
site
two years later rms titanic incorporated
a for-profit company mounted the first
of many salvage operations
the titanic has even become a tourist
destination
very sad but very beautiful and it was
very emotional for me
something i wanted to do all my life
seen all the pictures
but nothing compares to seeing it right
there
for the lucky few who can afford the 60
000
fee visitors can board russian subs and
dive to the shipwreck
with each visit the titanic pays a price
they're right there see those big orange
that's where the submarines have been
landing and you can see it's just
it's breaking down the deck it's
crushing it
when you see orange that's a freshly
exposed surface
that's not natural that's being done by
the people coming and loving the thing
to death
with no international agreements in
place to protect the ship
ballard sees dramatic changes since
1985.
the titanic is becoming junkyard you'll
see big piles of chain and big
bags and you know there's a lot of trash
down there
up here we're now going up traversing
the mast
and when we found it it had a crow's
nest in ballard's first dives
he filmed the crow's nest where lookout
spotted the iceberg that doomed the
titanic
now that crucial piece of history is
gone
apparently knocked into a cargo hold by
a passing submarine
it's really sad when i look at the
damage
that's been done by the submarines
we in many ways open pandora's box
if the titanic is not protected
and there's no guard on duty it'll get
stripped
it'll get stripped until all the jewels
have been taken off the old lady's body
on the 100th anniversary of the titanic
disaster
ballard is on a quest to save the ship
before it's too late
so we're going to actually begin where
it was built up here in northern ireland
what i want to do is to reconstruct the
real story of the titanic
from its birthplace in belfast to its
final destination
in new york city and he wants to hear
directly from the families of an elite
team of titanic heroes
men who designed the ship built her with
their own hands
and were selected to sail on her maiden
voyage
to track down their families ballard
will rely on an international network of
researchers
including a titanic buff who doesn't
collect artifacts
he collects passengers i have all 2208
people that were on titanic listed in
here
their birth certificates their death
certificates their wills their
immigration papers passports
phil gowan's interest in the titanic
began at an early age
i can remember very clearly my mother
saying
that boat sank 50 or 60 years ago
why do you care about it now i guess i
wanted to know
what caused certain people to survive
and others to lose their lives
deep in gallons research is information
on the men charged with making sure the
titanic's maiden voyage went smoothly
they were called the guarantee group
in that group you had a master
electrician
plumbers draftsmen they were checking to
see that
everything that they had put together
was according to design
bob ballard comes to the city that these
men called home
where the titanic first rose to life
belfast northern ireland
well the titanic story begins in belfast
this was a community of shipbuilders and
built some of the greatest ships of all
a century ago this dry dock was the
largest on the planet
built for an epic new class of ocean
liner
here tens of thousands constructed the
most massive moving objects ever built
including a ship they knew as yard
number 401
history remembers her by another name
everything about the titanic is titanic
there's nothing small everything is is
huge
just look at this this is where they
installed the massive
propellers they would have been right in
front of me three of them
gigantic blades that are now on the
bottom of the north atlantic
at the end of that dock i saw this wall
of steel and it it just reminded me of
the moment i saw the titanic
that was a flashback to the moment of
discovery
this was built for the same steel the
same rivets
that's the side of the titanic
this is the first thing i saw the side
of the ship
it was just monumental because you can't
see
very far under the ocean
and so you're exploring this vast part
of our planet
with a flashlight and so you're shining
your flashlight and then all of a sudden
something comes into view
that really speaks to me more so than
anything
yet rivets and steel are only part of
the story
getting to the heart of the titanic
tragedy means finding the men
who risked everything to save belfast's
greatest creation
[Music]
bob ballard has come to northern ireland
to explore titanic's past
but his real concern is the shipwreck's
future
ever since humans have built great
things like the pyramids of giza or the
tombs of the maya
looters have been there the next day
evidence presented to a federal court
suggests an unauthorized expedition to
the titanic
took place in 2002 and
experts worry that more rogue groups
have plans for 2012.
now that we're moving away from using
manned vehicles to rovs
there are thousands of them and they're
in the hands of private people
so now the ball game has changed the
titanic's at greater peril now than ever
before
if the titanic is plundered for her
artifacts the impact might be felt most
in her hometown of belfast
this was the home of the guaranty group
a team of workers who built the titanic
and would sail on her maiden voyage
for these men creating the titanic was
the pinnacle of a decades-long process
and
it all happened here at the shipyards of
harlan and wool at one point
harlan and wolf was the ship builder to
the world
now there was other companies that were
just as good but harlan and wolf was
probably known best of all for being an
all-around shipyard in other words the
majority of the fittings under ships
were built right on site
harland and wolf had an exclusive
agreement to build ships for the white
star line
manufacturing almost every part of great
ocean liners
from their steel hulls to their
elaborate interiors
white starline and harlem wolf were just
incredible
ship builders those two changed the way
people travel
across the ocean every ship that you see
now
has got inspiration from harlan the wolf
on whether they know it or not
[Music]
one worker at harland and wolfe was a
young man who would be forever linked to
the titanic
thomas andrews thomas andrews was a
well-connected young man
his uncle was lord peary who was
in effect the owner of harland and wolf
andrews was an apprentice at first and
worked his way through various
departments and got a taste for the
whole shipbuilding industry
soon thomas was a rising star and his
uncle put him in charge of the design of
new ocean liners
its nepotism to the nth degree however
in this instance this man was qualified
for the job
everybody loved thomas andrews they
called him tommy he was a very
personable man he would walk around in
the shipyard he would talk to the
workers he would actually listen to him
and try to do something for him
[Applause]
andrews found himself on the leading
edge of a cutthroat industry
in an age when airplanes and automobiles
were in their infancy the steamship
was king
[Applause]
in order to be the most competitive
business out there in transatlantic
shipping
you wanted to have the state-of-the-art
elevators
telephones had come into the rooms in
some of them
these were things that were going to
lure customers away from the competition
the first decade of the 20th century saw
an ocean liner arms race
between the white star line and cunard
kunar took a commanding lead in 1907
with the mauritania
and lusitania the largest and fastest
ships on earth
white star struck back with ships 100
feet longer
and unparalleled in luxury
with elaborate smoking rooms gymnasiums
and heated swimming pools
the first ship in this new class would
be called olympic
the second titanic
with the olympic and titanic they really
outdid cunard and they went
way over the top their ships were so big
that they had a problem finding a harbor
in order to dock them in because nothing
was deep enough
building these ships in belfast meant
building a whole new infrastructure
to come here is to feel the titanic
because you can see where it was built
where it was outfitted
and there's tremendous amount associated
with the building of the ship here
like the offices of the man who oversaw
the construction of the titanic
thomas andrews he's the architect he's
the most
qualified person the most knowledgeable
person about the titanic
i have the greatest respect for him to
actually be
in his room in
belfast at harlan wolfes pretty special
pretty special i can imagine him
standing here
fire burning pondering the plants
seeing something that's wrong and
correcting something
probably had a pen right here and
made his notes and rolled him up and
carried him across the hall
this is the place where they built it
this
is her as far as i'm concerned her true
home
as the design and construction of the
titanic got underway
thousands of belfast workers were also
competing
for a rare honor the chance to join
thomas andrews on the ship's
guarantee group they all had their
specialties you know
they didn't just pick four guys at
harlan the wolf and say hey you want to
go for a ride
only eight workers out of more than ten
thousand would be chosen for the maiden
voyage
with the 9th thomas andrews as their
leader
it was the honor of a lifetime the
guaranty group
were the experts they knew the titanic
better than
anyone the white star line and the crew
were just taking
over the operation of the titanic but
the guaranty group were the ones that
built it
[Music]
bob ballard has tracked down the
descendant of one guarantee group member
they've come to what was once harland
and wolf's design department
the drawing offices where draftsman
planned out the entire ship
by hand roderick chisholm who was
chief draftsman and part of the guaranty
group was my great-grandfather
roderick was the right-hand man of
thomas and
his number two yeah yes i was told that
nobody knew the ship
better than thomas andrews and roderick
chisholm
in this room andrews and chisholm
oversaw the designs for olympic and
titanic
i find it just incredible that these men
without the use of calculators
or electronics can build something like
this there's so many calculations
and there's so much work you know they
didn't have a tape measure that measured
out 882 feet 9 inches
harlem wool didn't just build the ship
they filled her out
so it just shows you what we belfast
people are like
yes so that was great modesty
i mean we're a talented belfast and i
think you know
titanic that was a disaster and it was a
tragedy and it was
awful but she was magnificent
and she spoke of what belfast is
magnificent
as chief draftsman of this tremendous
endeavor
roderick chisholm was a natural choice
to sail on the maiden voyage
how they chose they probably took the
best to the best
well i'm assuming they did but i mean
that would have been an awesome honor
and
a real privilege to be in that group to
be in that group
chisholm played another key role
designing the titanic's
lifeboats but he didn't have a say
in the number of lifeboats thomas
andrews requested as many as 64.
he wanted more lifeboats in the ship he
made an argument for it and of course he
was shot down
the heads of harlan and wolf and the
white star line wanted more deck space
and less clutter they insisted
on no more than 20 lifeboats four more
than the legal minimum
it would be a fateful decision for
everyone on board
[Music]
[Music]
is intense at the auction in england as
collectors compete for artifacts
from titanic's hometown
what we've got is a collection of
material relating to
belfast belfast was the home of the
titanic
it was where titanic was built it was
where she spent all of her life
this is a young man johnny kelly he was
a worker at harlan the wolf
he was one of the first men to die on
titanic he died in june 1910 he fell
from gantry
age 19 almost two years before she sank
beneath the north atlantic
we have one of titanic's rivets or never
made it onto titanic
one of over three million from the ship
and finally
two letters relating to the guarantee
group men who were on the titanic
employed by harlan the wolf
to ensure that the elements of the ship
worked if there was an electrical issue
if there was a plumbing issue
these specialists would be on hand to
solve this problem
bob ballard is piecing together the
story of the guarantee group
with the help of ancestry.com and the
belfast titanic society
he's come to the village of cumber
ancestral home of the group's leader
thomas andrews i remember when i was
first thinking about
trying to find her and i thought
immediately of
thomas andrews because that was the
person i
in all my research i had the deepest
respect for
yes and and we're now celebrating the
great achievement not just by one man
right
uncle tommy but by all his workmates
when you look at the state of the
technology and
shipbuilding it was really the the
the cutting edge yeah it was at the
pinnacle of technology at the peak of
the british empire
it was an exciting time and belfast was
the forefront of all that
but some have said there's a fatal flaw
in thomas andrews design of the titanic
to find out ballard has come to a
conservation lab
outside belfast to examine the original
ship plans
they've never been filmed before we are
fortunate to be the repository
for the harlem wolf ship plan collection
which includes
the original designs for olympic and
titanic
well this is a very familiar drawing to
me
i see the forward mast in the crow's
nest and the ship spell
this drawing here of the of the poop
deck the after
section of the titanic really for me
has such symbolism because as the bow
went down
people just kept progressing backwards
and backwards to the stern
and finally they came to there was
nowhere to go they just
jumped jumping in most cases to their
death
100 years later experts still want to
know if the titanic was a ticking time
bomb
her fate written into her plans
the answer might lie in titanic's twin
sister
built from the same set of drawings the
olympic
this has caused a lot of confusion over
time as you can see from the profiles
here
this is the olympic and this is the
titanic unless you knew what you were
looking at
you would confuse one for the other
while almost
identical on paper titanic and olympic
had strikingly different careers
olympic really had the career in a sense
that titanic would have had
hundreds of crossings had it not met its
tragic fiat
the olympic was known as old reliable
with over 20 years of distinguished
service
built from the same plants the titanic
should have lasted at least as long
there was no design flaws in that ship
that ship
was built to withstand any of the
stresses and strains that are brought on
even by the heaviest throughout the
atlantic gales it was not
designed to side swipe icebergs
as they used to say in belfast she was
all right when she left us
and she was in good hands as the titanic
rose above the belfast skyline
thomas andrews was joined on the
guaranty group by the best and brightest
at harlan and wolfe
among them chief draftsman roderick
chisholm
electrician william parr and artie frost
a master fitter whose family still keeps
the tools of his trade
i have an item here that belonged to my
grandfather and this whistle uh was a
most useful thing to have because
when you were done holland wolves in
those days riveting was a
very very noisy job
if you wanted to draw somebody's
attention that to the fact you wanted to
speak to them
you used the whistle because they
wouldn't have heard you if you shouted
still works can i use it i won't blow
anything
in 1912 artie frost got word that he'd
been chosen to represent his department
on the guaranty group not everybody got
sent in the guaranteed group
and an awful lot of the employees would
have loved to have gone
rounding out this distinguished group
was engineer robert knight
and four up-and-coming apprentices
including a 21 year old named
francis parks my uncle was a plumber
and he was 21 when he was on the taste
test and he came out as a top
apprentice right and he was selected to
go on this so it was a great honor oh
great honored great honor
to be on this the ship so when did you
first i mean as soon as you were born i
imagine there can remember
it must have entered your life the story
of the titanic oh it was something that
you it was a tragedy
that you didn't talk about it was an
embarrassment it was an embarrassment
yeah
the sinking of the titanic was a
tremendous embarrassment
to the city of belfast to harlan and
wolf to the very heart of this community
and it was not something they wanted to
talk about
yet when titanic was ready to sail she
was the toast of belfast
thomas andrews and the rest of the
guaranty group boarded the ship on april
2nd 1912
bound for southampton and ultimately new
york
i can only guess what thomas andrews and
the guaranty group
might have felt when they first stepped
aboard but
satisfaction is what it had to be
because nothing had ever been like this
before
and the fact that it had been conceived
drafted
constructed and now it was a finished
product
had to be the ultimate climax for their
lives
at that point
[Music]
the titanic took on passengers and crew
at southampton
eight days after leaving its birthplace
in belfast
as the journey began the guarantee group
set to work
inspecting all aspects of the ship
from the engine room to the bridge
and from the four kitchens to the
luxurious dining rooms
until the fifth night at z
april 14 1912
titanic steaming at 22 knots
a quiet sunday night interrupted by the
sound
of an iceberg tearing into the ship
at this critical moment captain edward
smith
turns to the man who knows the titanic
best
when they hit the iceberg captain smith
summoned thomas andrews
captain asked him to go below dexton
and assess the damage to the ship which
he knew so well
and he went below decks and walked the
compartments and
returned to the bridge and told the
captain
it's going to sink
despite being designed with 16 water
tight compartments
andrews knew that no ship is truly
unsinkable titanic was built to a two
compartment standard
we could have any of these two
compartments flooded whether it be this
one
and this one or this one and this one
and she would be able to sail back the
port without a problem
you could even have the first four
watertight compartments flooded
at the same time and it wouldn't be an
issue however you can't
damage one two three four and five
that was a death knoll to the ship what
happens is there's too much weight
if you have too many watertight
compartments flooded the ship's gonna
sink
[Music]
soon after andrews broke the news to the
captain the outside world got its first
clue that titanic was in danger
you had the wireless for the first time
on some of these ships
and they began to get word that
something was up
distress calls emanated from the
greatest ship on the ocean
people couldn't believe their ears they
thought no this has got to be a mistake
surely that ship couldn't sink
in titanic's hometown families of the
ship's guarantee group
waited anxiously for word rumors in
belfast were rife
at the time and my grandmother must have
been a very worried person because
she had heard the titanic had sank
she had also heard that titanic had been
towed into
port without loss of life and she didn't
know
for three or four days whether her
husband was alive or dead
the news came first to new york
this was titanic's destination the goal
of hundreds of
immigrants on board and the home of many
of the ships
rich and famous the white star line
offices at the southern tip of manhattan
now became
the focal point of the titanic drama
well right behind me is bowling green
park at the tip of manhattan island
right across the street here at the end
of broadway is where the white star line
had their headquarters
this is where the report started coming
in that the titanic
had hit an iceberg april 14th but by
late
on the 15th the true story began to
unfold
an ocean liner called the carpathia had
come to the titanic's rescue
but they arrived too late to save the
ship
instead they picked up lifeboats filled
with survivors
and sent lists of names to new york by
radio
they started posting the names of the
survivors
and the family members came to find out
if their relatives and friends
lived or died on the titanic
[Music]
imagine a trickle of people that began
to assemble in this park and then it
just got
bigger and bigger hundreds and hundreds
of people
assembling here directly across the
street
wondering some went up
read the good news a lot never saw the
name
they hoped for and went away in tears
the scene repeated itself on both sides
of the atlantic
as each new name went on the list a
family would breathe a sigh of relief
yet days later there was still no word
on the nine men of the guarantee group
[Music]
the rescue ship carpathia arrived in new
york on the night of april 18
1912 packed with hundreds of titanic
survivors
it was a mob scene there were people's
names
that were included as having died that
actually had survived in vice versa so
people discovered for the first time
that night what had really happened
as survivors told their stories they
began to shed light
on the leader of the guarantee group
thomas andrews
thomas andrews was you know trying to
assist getting life jackets out
for his testimony that you know that he
told one woman
you know here's your life jacket take it
and go
he didn't heed his own advice
thomas andrews was seen in the first
class smoking room towards the end
he was standing beside a big painting
that was
above the fireplace and he was staring
out into the distance
he gave up his life he didn't even
bother to put on a life jacket
he didn't even bother to go up to the
boat deck he
was last seen admiring his ship and went
down with her
[Music]
and the rest of the guaranty group artie
frost and william parr were last seen in
the ship's engine room
likely fighting to keep the lights on so
more passengers could escape
the guaranty group i'm sure were very
involved in the final moments of the
titanic
because they were the ones that truly
understood
what had happened to the ship and were
trying to do their best to save her
they were never seen again none of the
guarantee group survived
the fact that none of their bodies were
ever found that there really
aren't accounts indicates that they
didn't really make any attempt to get
into lifeboats or save themselves
it doesn't appear that any of them even
tried
this is the postcard my grandfather
artie frost sent to my father
stanley just before he got on the
titanic at southampton
and sailed away it says
how would you like to be fishing off
this pier
don't be having any more falls my father
just fallen off his bike and taking the
knee off himself
and he was hobbling around at that time
and that's picture off the pier at
southampton where the titanic was
tied up this was the last word the
family had
from this card when they never heard
from him again
[Music]
and that does something to me when i say
that
of the 2 200 people on titanic's maiden
voyage
only 700 survived more than
1500 died
as early as 1912 families of the victims
proposed expeditions to locate the
wreckage
yet even as deep sea technology improved
the titanic remained beyond reach
for 73 years
for bob ballard it took a clue from a
titanic survivor to show him the way
at the pier in new york where survivors
came ashore
ballard meets the grandson of jack
thayer
jack was one of the last people to jump
from the stern of the titanic
and live he and a friend jumped from the
same rail at the same time
his friend didn't survive he did so it
was
just probably by sheer luck
and by finding an overturned lifeboat
and having some place to
sort of call home for the night he was
able to get out of the water directly
jack's account was one of the first to
say the titanic broke in half
as it sank he said the rumble and the
roar continued
with even louder distinct wrenching and
tearing
of boilers and engines from their beds
suddenly the whole
superstructure of the ship appeared to
split
that's that's what led me to realize
that the ship broke in half and dumped
out its contents
the story he told gave me an idea
on how to find her and that was not to
look
for the titanic but i would look for the
debris that came off the titanic because
i knew its footprint
would be much larger and predictable we
knew the currents so we knew
the debris field should be north south
and that's huge because now i have a
line
this way i search this way and sure
enough i picked up the footprints
and it led me to the titanic
but now that ballard has found the
titanic he faces
a far more daunting task finding a way
to protect it
and its thousands of priceless artifacts
[Music]
as the titanic auction concludes the net
sales add up to over three hundred
thousand dollars
we had a really motivated crowd here
today very enthusiastic collectors
who were vying to buy some very
interesting pieces and we were very
pleased how today went
the keys from the titanic sell for more
than fifty five
thousand dollars two guarantee group
artifacts
go for more than seven hundred dollars
each they are letters of condolence to
the grieving families
some of the items in the auction are
bound for museums
others will disappear from public view
as more and more items fall into private
hands
there remains a key storehouse for
titanic artifacts
the ship itself
and it's only getting easier to reach
what was once
an inaccessible depth much of the
technology we use today to explore
in the ocean those are the grandchildren
of the tools we used on titanic
this technology used to be the exclusive
domain of elite oceanographers
but those days are numbered today
if you've got the money it's very easy
to go out and find a ship
to find a robot get the cables get the
crew together to go look at some place
like titanic
let's face it titanic's a thousand miles
from new york it's 400 miles from
newfoundland
pretty hard to enforce that site so far
away
there's no international laws any rogue
organization could go out there
i'm mostly concerned about the
technology now to get inside
and that's where the preservation's the
highest
and most of the contents are there
after decades of waiting an
international treaty and u.s legislation
are now on the table and could start
protecting the ship
as early as 2012. bob ballard believes
the same rovs that make it easier to
reach the titanic
could also make it easier to police do
i expect others to go after artifacts
from the titanic
covertly or quietly yes now is there
technology that we could build centuries
absolutely could we have guards yes
easily
in fact a pilot project in the pacific
will allow robots to constantly monitor
the ocean floor
a system that could someday provide
24-hour security for the titanic
[Music]
but to ballard any solution starts with
the people
most affected by the tragedy how would
you like this site treated in the future
i would like to be left as it is that's
my uncle's graveyard
hey you don't desecrate her grave i know
my great-grandfather roderick
he's down there i don't know that's his
grave and i know my grandmother
was extremely adamant that should not be
touched
the graves of all of them shouldn't be
tampered with and i would
every person i've spoken to that has
any relationship that the titanic have
all
said please protect this ship you know
my grandfather
remember being at the launch and i can
still hear his booming voice saying that
it should be left to rest in peace
that's my hope and
certainly all the survivors when i first
found her there were several survivors
that were still alive and they all felt
the same way
it's really important that it's left
yeah as a memorial as a
as a monument to the the great work that
went on in belfast
in downtown belfast a monument stands in
honor of
22 local men who lost their lives
on april 15 1912.
nine of them belong to the guarantee
group
[Music]
i didn't really get touched
by the titanic until i found it you know
i'm a scientist and i looked at it as a
technical thing and
but when we found it that was it
it really hit me and i was surprised
for the guarantee group and for over a
thousand others who died on the titanic
this ship is their grave
every inch is sacred ground
every artifact a memorial
[Music]
you know my feeling is if you can't
protect the titanic
there's nothing in the sea you can
protect
so that's why i want to stand my ground
we're not done until it's protected
[Music]
you